you've heard athletes you've heard
actors you've heard other celebrities
speak out about their mental health but
chances are you have not heard from any
in the business community business
leaders they don't say much about this
subject andy dunn though is different
he's co-founder of the men's clothing
retailer bonobos and he's working to
change the stigma around mental illness
he's sharing his experience with bipolar
disorder
which he's kept hidden until now in a
brave and candid new memoir burn rate
launching a startup and losing my mind
he tackles the stigma surrounding mental
illness
in the business world and he writes
let's for everyone's sake stop
pretending that it's not here that we're
not here andy dunn is with us this
morning and we're glad about that you're
right in the in the front of this book
that this is not a guide for
entrepreneurs it's not about how to
launch your startup it really is a book
about mental health yeah and the last
taboo the business community doesn't
talk about this why did you decide to do
it well it's funny when my editor first
heard the pitch he said if he rejected
it
he said if andy is looking to write a
chess thumping memoir about being an
entrepreneur i'm not interested but if
you're willing to tell a story an
unvarnished story about mental illness
that happens to be told through the lens
of an entrepreneur then maybe i'm in
yeah you call it a ghost story uh and
the ghost being your mental health
challenges your bipolar disorder when
did that haunting to keep the metaphor
intact start
22 years ago so i was a senior in
college i ended up with messianic
delusions elevated speech patterns i
stopped eating i stopped drinking i was
up for
sleeping for four nights in a row wow
and i ended up hospitalized in the
psychiatric ward i spent a week there
i came back down to earth thanks to
medication i was diagnosed with bipolar
disorder type one and then what happened
was tragic which is we just buried it we
decided it hadn't happened i'd use
psilocybin mushrooms for the first time
a few weeks earlier and everyone just
hung their hat that that was the reason
for the psychosis when in fact while
substance abuse and mental illness can
be intersecting it didn't mean that the
bipolar disorder wasn't there in fact
you had two two professionals tell you
that you probably didn't have bipolar
disorder that it was a one-off episode
that it's not something you need to to
worry about but i i echo what what tony
says about how brave i think it is for
you to reveal this number one i did not
know your story andy when you said
losing my mind i thought it meant the
struggles in putting a startup together
the stress of being a businessman yes
that's exactly what i thought nate and
then i start reading i go holy i can't
believe how candid you are in the things
that happened to you you when you talk
about bipolar you said it's a forever
diagnosis there is no cure there's a
bomb in your brain that could go off at
any time so i'm wondering how you live
today knowing this that it's a bomb in
your brain that could go off at any time
yeah so on exit the diagnosing
psychiatrist said something in
retrospect tragic she said if andy
doesn't have another event for the next
five years it could be that this was a
one-off psychotic event yeah and we as a
family hung our hat on that and then the
worst possible thing happened which i
was asymptomatic for 10 years
and then i started dealing with
catatonic depression and suicidal
ideation during the time of building a
startup
until in 2016 this second manic episode
struck and i spent a week in bellevue
hospital
finally everyone was clear-eyed i had my
girlfriend come in my parents and sister
and all these loved ones i walked out
ready to deal with it and i walked
straight out into handcuffs yes and i
was arrested for felony and misdemeanor
assault in an episode of violence during
the mania and that was the wake-up call
don't remember exactly and when you talk
about you considered suicide not to end
your life but to end the depression
there's a difference there's a
difference they say hunger is because
you want to you eat because you want to
end your the the act of being hungry and
so what's been so sad as the books come
out is i've gotten all these notes from
so many families where they have mental
illness in the family bipolar sword and
the family and so frequently those folks
are gone you know the suicide attempt
rate for bipolar one is sixty percent
the suicide rate is twenty percent and
so really it is you've gotta survive and
that means therapy that means medication
daily and it is
therapy is not enough
that's right
this book describes the intersection
between mental illness and
entrepreneurship what advice would you
give to individuals out there that are
trying to build a business i feel like
we have more active minds trying to be
young businessmen and women today more
now than ever yeah um but some of them
do lose their mind in the process
entrepreneurs seem to have higher rates
of depression anxiety and even bipolar
someone has been through it what advice
would you give those people so first i
think it's just we need to acknowledge
there's a relationship between
creativity and disorder and we've
noticed it in the entertainment world
we're starting to talk about in sports
but in business we're not that's strong
and so i think the first thing we need
to do is acknowledge that it's there
and then make the space for people to
disclose their issue we need to
normalize disclosure
and so that's kind of the first step
because you say i am no one says i am
cancer they said i have cancer yeah i
mean analogy is important that is key
it's so important i was told i am
bipolar even when i wrote the book i
wrote it
and then it's like well wait a second i
am not bipolar i have bipolar disorder
in the same way that someone isn't
cancer they have cancer yeah
and the business world is hungry for
stability and that's why there's such a
stigma around this but talking about it
and showing you still can't perform at a
high level and there's life after is
really what makes this book so important
married with a baby yeah congratulations
you two got through all of that together
and you married me did my wife manuela
you know she stuck by me through this
and you can imagine
um after what we went through with the
violence i struck her during that
episode the fact that she stayed with me
that her mom said andy it's just like
diabetes you got to take care of
yourself it was really healing that's
the way to put it that's true
thank you andy dunn thank you very much
the book is burn rate it's brave it's on
sale right now pick it up